EVERYONE TO THE WEDNESDAY JUNE
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU HERE CHIU HERE MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTIONED HERE CHAO.
CHOI HERE CHILLY HERE GLORIA.
GLORIA HERE WE MONTH.
THE MONEY HERE WOULD.
I DO HAVE A QUORUM ONE A WELCOME
SENATOR ROTH UP
TO.
PRESENT FILE ITEM TO IT SP
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
CENTER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
PERTAINS TO HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS IN ASSOCIATION
RESIDENTS SENATE ESSENTIALLY HAS
THREE PARTS FIRST ALLOWS
RESIDENTS OF COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS THE ASSOCIATION'S.
TOP TEN BY EMAIL TO RECEIVE
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS SUCH AS ANNUAL
BUDGETS AN ANNUAL POLICY
STATEMENTS BY EMAIL. OPTING IN
VIA EMAIL.
SECOND IT CHANGES A NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FOR PROPOSED RULE
CHANGES FROM.
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS FROM THIRTY
DAYS IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE
MORE EFFECTIVE CALENDAR RING OF
MEETINGS.
AND FINALLY THE BILL ALLOWS FOR.
PERHAPS THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL
PIECE ALLOWS FOR ELECTION BY
ACCLAMATION IN THE EVENT THAT A
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES SEEKING
ELECTION IS EQUAL TO.
OR FEWER THAN A NUMBER OF BOARD
SEATS AVAILABLE.
WE'VE ADDED A PROVISION THIS
ACCLAMATION SECTION THAT
INSURERS PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY
FOR PARTICIPATION ELECTION BY
REQUIRING THE ELECTION RULES AND
NOMINATION PROCEDURES.
WE PERSONALLY PROVIDED TO
RESIDENTS THIRTY DAYS BEFORE THE
NOMINATION DEADLINE SO IN
ESSENCE IF AT THE END OF A VERY
FULL ON ROBUST NOMINATION
PROCESS YOU HAVE THREE
CANDIDATES FOR THREE SEATS.
GIVEN THESE PROCEDURES IF
THEY'RE FOLLOWED THE ELECTION
CAN PROCEED BY ACCLAMATION AS
OPPOSED TO THE NORMAL. OF DETAIL
PROCESS I KNOW THERE'S SOME.
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE UNDER
CONSIDERATION BY THE COMMITTEE
THAT ARE BEING WORKED AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO INCREASE EVEN FURTHER
THE TRANSPARENCY.
HERE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
YOUR MEMBERS AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY AND. MOVING
THOSE AMENDMENTS FORWARD AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME.
GREAT THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES.
HI KATHY VAN ALSTYNE THEM DAMN
STRATEGY GROUP REPRESENTING
LAGUNA WOODS VILLAGE.
I WOULD TO SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION.
.
AND.
LAGUNA WOODS VILLAGE AS A
DEVELOPMENT THAT HOUSE.
THREE THREE MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS
WITHIN.
WITHIN ITS BOUNDARIES.
THERE ARE TWELVE AND A HALF
THOUSAND HOMES WITHIN THIS
DEVELOPMENT I MORE THAN EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND.
THE WE'VE TALKED WITH THE THE
THE SENATOR MENTIONED THOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS IN A CLEAN
UP IN THAT SOME THE FEASIBILITY
ISSUES THAT WOULD REFLECT THAT
WE TRY TO IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN.
SAVE SOME OF THERE ARE RESOURCES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING
IT BACK INTO THE SERVICES.
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION THAT
OUR RESIDENTS DESERVE.
MOST OF.
OUR RESIDENTS ARE ON AND.
MODEST FIXED COME. OTHER. SENIOR
COMMUNITY FIFTY FIVE AND OLDER.
A HAVE. A CHALLENGE.
WE HAVE THREE DIFFERENT BOARD
MEETINGS EVERY YEAR OF FOR EACH
OF THESE DEVELOPMENTS
LAST YEAR WE HAD THREE. THREE
CHORD ELECTIONS.
AND NONE WERE COMPETITIVE WE
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH.
MEMBERS WHO NOMINATED
THEMSELVES TO WORK TO RUN.
AND.
SO WE SPENT.
BETWEEN SIXTY AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON ELECTIONS IN
WHICH THE OUTCOME IS
PREDETERMINED ALREADY.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT.
AT A AT A MEANS TO. BE FRUGAL
WITH OUR OUR RESIDENTS
RESOURCES.
AND.
MAKE SURE THAT I HAVE BEEN UP
WE CAN GET PEOPLE TO RUN WE'D
LIKE PEOPLE TO RUN AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE. BUT IN THE EVENT THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH CANDIDATES
WE WOULD LIKE TO EXERCISE THE.
SAME ABILITY THAT I
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS HAVE SCHOOL BOARDS
HAVE WHICH IS TO BE ABLE TO
ELECT BY ACCLAMATION. IF THERE
ARE NOT ENOUGH CANDIDATES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE WERE HERE TODAY
IN IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. HOW
WANT TO THANK? STAFF FOR THE
ANALYSIS WHICH POINTS OUT THAT
THIS.
NO IS IT IS NOT. ANYTHING
ENTIRELY NEW.
THIS IS DONE AND THERE IS IT'S
DONE IN MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS
NOTHING I WOULD LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS THAT.
THE. ELECTION PROCESS IN THE
DAVIS STIRLING ACT IS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE.
I'M AND ONE THING IS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A CERTAIN QUORUM OF
BALLOTS THAT A RETURN BEFORE.
THEY CAN ACTUALLY BE COUNTED.
THERE ARE A NUMBER F SITUATIONS
WHERE THAT QUORUM IS NOT REACHED
SO IN THE SITUATION THAT WE'RE
WE'RE HAVING HERE IS IT YOU MAY
HAVE MEMBERS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
WANTING TO BE. A BOARD MEMBERS
AND RUNNING FOR THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
AND THROUGH THE EXISTING BALLOT
PROCESS IF THAT QUORUM MINIMUM
QUORUM OF RETURN BALLOTS IS NOT
ACHIEVED THOSE MEMBERS CANNOT.
BECOME BOARD MEMBERS
SO THIS THIS ACTUALLY DOES IN
SOME WAYS HELP US GET NEW BOARD
MEMBERS ON TO ABORT ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE ARE FEWER CANDIDATES
THEN THERE ARE. VACANCIES OR
EQUAL TO NUMBER ALLOWS FOR THAT
TRANSITION OF LEADERSHIP TO
HAPPEN WHEN WE DO FACE VOTER
APATHY WHICH DOES HAPPEN QUITE A
BIT.
IN A CHOI ELECTION SO OF FOR
THOSE REASONS AND THE REASON
CENTER ROTH PRESENTED WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
OTHER SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
JENNIFER WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS IN SUPPORT.
AND AT THIS TIME LET ME ASK IF
THERE IS OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
.
GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR AND TO
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MARJORIE MURRAY. CENTER FOR
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION LAW. WE
REPRESENT HOMEOWNERS WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS.
.
FIRST I WILL SAY WHY DOES
ANYBODY CARE ABOUT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS.
FOR THE SIMPLE REASON.
THAT HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS ARE
NOT COUNTRY CLUBS.
THERE NOT CASUAL NEIGHBORHOOD
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ORGANIZE.
I A JULY FOURTH PICNICS.
THIS IS ANOTHER LEVEL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT HAS BEEN MADE
QUITE CLEAR BY THE CALIFORNIA
UP.
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY POWERS.
OVER THE LIVES AND THE PROPERTY
OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE AND
THAT POWER IS EXERCISED THROUGH
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
SO FOR THAT REASON WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
STATUTES GOVERNING HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS AND ANY
ATTEMPTS TO ELIMINATE THEM.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT
THIS TOPIC HAS BEEN BROUGHT
FORWARD THROUGH LEGISLATION THIS
IS THE THIRD EFFORT.
THE INDUSTRY IS DETERMINED TO
ELIMINATE ELECTIONS AND TO
REPLACE THEM
WITH ELECTIONS BY NOT NOT EVEN
ELECTIONS.
TO SEE BOARD DIRECTORS BY
ACCLAMATION.
AND ONE OTHER DISTRESSING THINGS
IS IT'S.
HOMEOWNERS REPORT TO US THAT
THIS IS ALREADY TAKING PLACE.
BOARD DIRECTORS ARE ALREADY
BEING SEATED BY ACCLAMATION.
AND SO THESE REPEATED ATTEMPTS
AB LEGISLATION ARE REALLY THE
PETITION BY THE ASSOCIATION
INDUSTRY.
TO ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO BLESS
A PLAQUE PRACTICE
ALREADY IN PLACE.
SO.
THE UNFORTUNATE THING ABOUT THIS
BILL IS THAT IT COMBINES TWO
POWERS.
BOARDS ALREADY HAVE UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE RIGHT TO SET
QUALIFICATIONS FOR BOARD
DIRECTORS.
IT'S A POWER THEY ABUSE
HOMEOWNERS REPORT TO US THAT THE
QUALIFICATIONS ARE THINGS LIKE
YOU HAVE TO SPEAK ENGLISH I'M
NOT KIDDING.
YOU CANNOT BE DISABLED YOU
CANNOT BE DEAF BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HIRE A SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER TO TELL YOU WHAT'S
GOING ON AT A BOARD MEETING.
YOU HAVE TO BE A FULL TIME
RESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION EVEN
IN THOSE ASSOCIATIONS COMPRISING
SECOND HOMES.
AND MOST DISTURBING YOU CANNOT
EVER HAVE SUED THE ASSOCIATION
IN THE PREVIOUS SIX YEARS OR TEN
YEARS OR WHATEVER. IN OTHER
WORDS YOU CANNOT BE A PERSON
ATTEMPTING TO EXERCISE HE ARE
YOUR RIGHTS THROUGH THE COURTS.
ALL OF THIS IS EXTREMELY
DISTURBING TO US.
SO ELECTIONS IN ASSOCIATIONS ARE
CRITICAL BECAUSE THESE ARE SELF
GOVERNING ORGANISATIONS.
MEMBERSHIP IS MANDATORY WHEN YOU
BUY AN ASSOCIATION HOME YOU HAVE
TO BELONG TO THE ASSOCIATION.
AND THE BOARD.
EXERCISES ITS POWER
UNDER AUTHORITY GRANTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. IT ALSO CONTROLS
ALL THE ASSOCIATION MONEY.
SO WE HAVE A COMBINATION OF
AUTHORITY AND RESOURCES.
WE ONLY CHECK ON WHICH
IS THE VOTE.
AND THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
REPLACE LEADERSHIP.
SO WE ARE EXTREMELY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SPELL WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE.
TO VOTE NO ON A.
AND TO SEE THAT A DOES NOT
PROCEED THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
AS THESE PREVIOUS ATTEMPTS.
HAVE ATTEMPTED.
.
FINALLY I WILL SAY THAT THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN THE RIGHT TO
RUN FOR OFFICE HAS BEEN
CONFERRED. BY.
AT THE MOMENT AND THE EVENT THAT
SOMEBODY BUYS AN ASSOCIATION
HOME.
SO IT'S CREATED THROUGH
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. IT'S BEEN
ELABORATED ON BY THE LEGISLATURE
THROUGH THE STATUTES.
CREATED.
THROUGH A BIPARTISAN EFFORT IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE TWO THOUSAND
SIX.
AND THESE RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
REAFFIRMED THROUGH THE COURTS.
SO WE URGE A NO VOTE ON THE
MEASURE.
S. WITNESS.
YES MY NAME IS TOM SIR I'M A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CENTER PRINT A
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
LAW.
I'M A RETIRED SUPERIOR COURT
COMMISSIONER AND I DO LIVE IN A
LARGE A SENIOR.
COMMUNITY IN A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT.
IN SOLANO COUNTY.
AND I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
POINT OUT THAT.
THE PROVISION ON A SEATING BY
ACCLAMATION IS REALLY A DUAL
THREAT TO THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
IN THIS WAY FIRST THERE'S.
WHAT?
MARJORIE IS POINTED OUT WHICH
IS THAT THERE ARE ONGOING ABUSES
OF THE EXISTING POWER TO SET
QUALIFICATIONS.
TO RUN FOR THE BOARD.
THIS SECOND THREAT IS THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THIS IS
DRAFTED.
IT IS ONE INDIVIDUAL KNOWN AS
THE INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS
WHO LOOKING AT THE SITUATION
CAN.
UNILATERALLY DECLARE A THAT
THERE IS THE RIGHT NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES AND THEREFORE CANCEL
THE ELECTION.
THISMAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE REALLY
ARE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO FOR
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH THAT
DECISION TO RAISE THE HEAT
CHALLENGE.
THERE'S NOTHING TO LITIGATE
THERE'S NO ELECTION THE STATUTES
ARE ALL WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY
THAT MEMBERS WHO DISAGREE WITH
THE WAY OF ELECTION IS GONE. HAS
THE RIGHT TO TO GO INTO COURT
INCLUDING SMALL CLAIMS COURT AND
REYES THESE CLAIMS BUT WITH NO
ELECTION. THERE'S NOTHING
THERE'S NO VEHICLE AND WE WITH
WHICH TO CHALLENGE.
SECONDLY.
IN ISSUES BEEN MADE THAT AND
REALLY THE PRIMARY.
JUSTIFICATION ADVANCE FOR THE
THIS SITUATION FOR THIS. A BILL.
ISN'T THERE WILL BE A COST
SAVING.
USING THE PROPONENTS OWN
STATISTICS WHERE THEY SAY THAT
THEY HAVE SPENT SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A THREE ELECTIONS ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ELECTION.
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND.
A RESIDENTS.
THAT WORKS OUT TO A DOLLAR
ELEVEN CENTS.
PER.
RESIDENT.
AND THAT IS A TINY COSTA P. TO
GUARANTEE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
JUST I JUST HAVE TO NOTE THAT
TYPICALLY H. AWAY DUES ARE
SEVERAL HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A TINY
FRACTION OF ONE MONTHS CESSPIT.
TO HAVE TO RETAIN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
THE.
COST WELL WORTH PAYING.
ON MARJORIE'S POINT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THIS IS ALREADY ON
GOING I HAVE TO SAY THAT IN MY
OWN ASSOCIATION.
ARE GOVERNING DOCUMENTS WERE
RECENTLY REVISED AT THE ADVICE
OF COUNSEL IN AND THE
ENCOURAGEMENT OF COUNSEL.
THREE INSERTED
A PROVISION FOR SEATING BY
ACCLAMATION.
SO AGAIN IT IS REALLY HAPPENING
ALREADY WHY DO WE NEED THIS BILL
AND I THINK MARJORIE'S
OBSERVATION IS A GOOD ONE.
AND FINALLY.
.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT.
IN COMPARING THIS SITUATION.
TO PUBLIC ELECTIONS ARE EITHER
SCHOOL BOARDS OR CITY COUNCILS.
THEIR SAFEGUARDS THERE THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO RUN FOR CITY
COUNCIL AND FOR SCHOOL BOARD.
ARE SET BY STATUTE THEY'RE NOT
SET BY THE SCHOOL BOARD ITSELF.
OR THE CITY COUNCIL ITSELF AND
SECONDLY YOU'LL NOTICE THAT IN
THE SCHOOL BOARD SITUATION
THERE'S A SAFEGUARD THERE WERE.
PEOPLE CAN RAISE AN OBJECTION
AND TRIED TO OVERTURN THE
DECISION TO SEAT PEOPLE BY
ACCLAMATION.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS I WOULD
AGAIN ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE THANK
YOU.
IS THERE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME.
HELLO MY NAME IS THERESA LUCAS
I'M FROM YOLO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GUS
PETRA BORG I'M FROM PLASTER
COUNTY.
DROVE AN HOUR AND A HALF TO GET
HERE THIS MORNING TO LODGE MY
OPPOSITION AS WELL AND JUST A
NOTE. I'M A FORMER ELECTED
DIRECTOR OF AN ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSING.
I'M MARGIE SUING ANY ANTI I'M
IN.
I'M A PRESENT BOARD MEMBER OF A
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
I'M OPPOSED TO THE ACCLAMATION
PORTION. AND I'M IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE JACKSON
I'M FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY I RAN
FOR.
ABOARD OFFICE UNDER VERY.
TENSION A DETENTION WRITTEN.
CIRCUMSTANCES AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GIVEN MY EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND UP LET ME
START WITH A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ARE. FIRST OF ALL
PROPITIATE THE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. I'LL JUST SAY
FOR MYSELF FROM A PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE FOR A FEW YEARS AGO
I MOVED INTO A BUILDING THAT.
HOUSING H. AWAY AND WE HAVE HAD
TROUBLE RECRUITING CANDIDATES.
FOR THE BOARD.
AND.
AND I DO KNOW THAT THIS IS A
SITUATION THAT IS IS VERY TRUE
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I DO THINK THAT THE
AUTHOR IS TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO BOTH
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. BUT IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE YOU DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH CANDIDATES TO ALLOW
FOR PROCESS.
TO MAKE THAT A LITTLE BIT
EASIER A BIT MORE EFFICIENT AND
AND NOT AS COSTLY. ARM I'D LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST CLARIFY
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE MY STAFF
I HAVE WORKED THROUGH WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF. OF THEIR TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WE HAD
PROPOSED ONE I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S NO CONTROVERSY ON AND
THAT IS.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE H. AWAY
HAVE ADOPTED ELECTION RULES AS
REQUIRED UNDER EXISTING LAW
WHICH INCLUDES PROCEDURE FOR
NOMINATIONS IN ORDER TO USE.
THE ELECTION BY ACCLAMATION
OPTION.
WE HAD ALSO PROPOSED A
LIMITATION ON ASIA WAYS TO HOLD.
OUR. EVERY OTHER ELECTION BY
ACCLAMATION TO AVOID
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH
POTENTIALLY ALL ELECTIONS ARE
MADE BY ACCLAMATION.
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF HAVE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT I AM OKAY
WITH FOR THIS COMMITTEE MOVING
FORWARD ALTHOUGH I DO THINK THIS
ISSUE NEEDS TO CAN BE CONTINUE
TO BE WORKED ON AND I SERVE ON
THE. ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHICH THIS BILL WILL
BE GOING TO NEXT AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THAT BUT LET ME JUST.
READ INTO THE RECORD.
WE WOULD ADD LANGUAGE THAT SAYS
THAT THERE'S A REQUIREMENT THAT
A ABORTED DIRECT ROUTE
REQUIREMENT THAT ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE BE IN THE THIRTY DAY
NOTICE. FOR THE ELECTION AND
NOMINATION PROCEDURES THAT
STATES THAT IF THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH CANDIDATES THE ELECTION
COULD BE DECIDED BY ACCLAMATION.
AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENT THAT THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ADOPT A RESOLUTION AT
A BOARD MEETING THAT FINDS AT
THE NUMBER OF CANDIDATES FOR THE
BOARD. IS EQUAL TO THE VACANCY
IS CREATED BY THE EXPIRING TERMS
THE THE REASON FOR THIS LANGUAGE
AGAIN IS TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES.
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM AS WELL
AS PART OF WHAT I WOULD LIKE THE
AUTHOR OF TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
IN THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IS THE IDEA THAT.
WE DO WHERE POSSIBLE WANT TO
FIND AND PUSH AND PROMOTE
COMPETITIVE ELECTIONS AND A WE
DON'T I THINK WANNA. SET UP LAWS
THAT ALLOW THE SPORTS TO HAVE
ACCLAMATION YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR THAT'S
THE CONCERN THAT. THAT I HAVE
HAD SO ON WITH THOSE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
UNPREPARED TO IT TO MOVE THIS
OUT OF COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WAS CENTER ROTH THAT
THAT'S. A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING I
KNOW THERE WAS A LOT OF. A GOOD
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN OUR STAFF
OF THE LAST FEW DAYS THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY MY UNDERSTANDING AS
WELL MISTER CHAIR GREAT. THANK
YOU LET ME ASK OUR MEMBERS IF
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS.
DOCTOR CHOI.
I DON'T THINK YOU SENATOR. I
THOUGHT OUT IN USUALLY I I I
JUST WAS SO RATHER SIMPLE.
BR.
SUGGESTING WHEN. NOT ENOUGH.
CANDIDATES ARE.
ELIGIBLE LAISSEZ THISA THREE
YEAR POSITIONS AND ANYONE WHAT
TO AND NOT TO SKIP THE.
ELECTION PROCESS.
IT U. IS THAT DOUBLE THE IN MY
STILL UNDERSTANDING AND CONNECT
TEST OF KATIE'S.
WHAT ABOUT THE US TEA AND ARE?
NOT ENOUGH.
CANDIDATES SO.
VOLUNTEER THAN THE HOW DO WE.
ALLOW THE BOARD MEMBERS HAVE TO
FEEL THAT THIS THAT.
THEY ARE TORE USE OF A
CANDIDATE AND THE THROUGH THE.
AFFIRMATION THAT THEY WANTED
OUT THEY WILL. CHOOSE TO BOARD
MEMBERS IT IS THAT THE INTENT.
DOCTOR YOU'RE CORRECT THAT THIS
BILL ONLY DEALS WITH THE
SITUATION WHERE AFTER OF. A
NOMINATION PROCESS AND AND
PUBLIC CITY PARKS PROCESS TO TRY
TO RECRUIT TO. FOLKS TO THE
BOARD WE ONLY HAVE YOU ONLY HAVE
THREE CANDIDATES FOR THREE SLOTS
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL. ADDRESSES
AMONG BUT FIRST I SHOULD COMMEND
THE OPPOSITION TO HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION FOLKS I.
HAVE I OWN PROPERTY IN A
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION IN MY
PRAYER LIVES I HAVE SERVED ON
THE BOARD I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES ON BOTH SIDES. OF
THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
DETERMINING WHO IS ELIGIBLE TO
VOTER WHO IS ELIGIBLE TO SERVE
AS A DIRECTOR AND. YOU WILL NOTE
FROM THE OPPOSITION COMMENTS
MOST OF THE CONCERN. A SEEMS TO
BE CENTERED AROUND ASSOCIATION
AND ORGANIZATIONS THAT ATTEMPT
TO RESTRICT.
MEMBERSHIP ON THE BOARD AND
PROGRAM MEMBERSHIP ON THE BOARD
AND THIS BILL DOES NOT TO DEAL
WITH THAT. YOU IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE HEARING ANOTHER BILL
NEXT WEEK BY ONE OF MY SENATE
COLLEAGUES TO TO ATTEMPT TO DEAL
SPECIFICALLY. WITH THAT ISSUE
WHICH IS THE LEAD UP TO THE
ELECTION PROCESS THIS BILL ONLY
DEALS WITH THE POINT WHERE THE
NOMINATION PROCESS IS OVER. THE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES HAS BEEN
DETERMINED AND THE NUMBER OF
CANDIDATES EQUALS THE NUMBER OF
SLOTS ECONOLINE ES YES I
RECOGNIZE THE CONCERN ABOUT THE.
THE PRELIMINARY ISSUE AND THAT
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH AND I'M
HAPPY TO WORK ON THAT AS WELL.
THE DANCE YOUR QUESTION SIR.
OKAY A PARTICULARLY THAT ARE PUT
OUT IF TO SOME FIVE MEMBER BOARD
THAT IS NOT WHEN I'M OR ANTI OF
FIVE. NOT THAT WOULD ULTIMATELY
THAT THOUGHT WHAT'S THREE YEAH
YEAH EACH TWO YEARS OR THREE
YEARS. WHEN WHEN THERE ARE THREE
VERY.
THREE POSITIONS ARE UP BUT AND.
TWENTY ONE. CANDIDATE THAT ONE
APPLICANT.
.
IT SUPPLY. AND IF TO SO.
STILL.
TOO THEY COOKED AND HOW DO WE
FEEL IS THAT THE TO. THE ACTING
POSITION THAT'S MY QUESTION.
SO THE THE. THE BILL DOES NOT
GIVE THE BOARD OF FORTY TWO
APPOINT SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT
NOMINATED THEMSELVES ARE BEEN
NOMINATED. OUGHT TO RUN FOR THE
BOARD IT HIT IT. IF AND WHEN
THAT HAPPENS SO.
YOU'LL YOU'LL BE ABLE DOES NOT
DETER WITH THAT HOW TO FEEL
THAT.
THOSE SHORTAGE OF TWO POSITIONS
CORRECT CORRECT UNDER THE
MUNICIPAL STATUTE WHERE YOU HAVE
ELECTION BY ACCLAMATION THERE IS
AN OPTION FOR THE CITY COUNCIL
TO ON BEHALF OF WHITE PERFORMING
ONLY ONE CANDIDATE WHO APPLY.
RIGHT RIGHT YEAH THAT ONE I CAN
BE OUR OWN YES THIS BILL DOES
NOT ONLY THAT NO PROBLEM BUT
THE.
THE REMAINING TWO POSITIONS ARE
LACKING THAT AND OUT TO THE
OPERATE THOUGH WITH THE. THREE
MEMBER BOARD. OR HOW DO WE.
ENCOURAGE THEM TO FEEL GOOD.
TO.
LACKING VACANCIES YES THIS BILL
DOES NOT SPEAK TO THOSE TO ADD
THOSE TWO VACANCIES THAT WERE
NOT FILLED. AYE DOES NOT GIVE
THE BOARD AUTHORITY TO A POINT
THAT THAT IT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION ILLUSTRATE THE WHEN THE
UP PAID THE THAT NUMBER BY
APPLICANTS ARE. EQUALLY Y. LAST
SECOND I SKIPPED A BEAT DOT THE
ELECTION PROCESS CORRECT OKAY A
GOD THINK.
THANK AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
TO.
THE SENATE AUTHOR SENT AUTHORS
POINT WE WILL BE HEARING A BILL
NEXT WEEK BY CENTER WHITE HOUSE
SKI THAT ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
ISSUES RAISED BY. THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA.
A HOMEOWNERSHIP.
ASSOCIATION AROUND.
SOME OF THE ALLEGATIONS OF.
INDIVIDUALS BEING DENIED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RUN FOR THE BOARD
SO WE WILL CERTAINLY BE TACKLING
THIS ISSUE NEXT WEEK BUT MR
GLORY LET ME GO BACK TO. SLEEP
THINKING OF A SHARED AND I WAS
GONNA BRING ON THAT POINT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T APPRECIATE THE
TESTIMONY OF.
OF SOME OF THE POOREST OF THIS
BILL RECOGNIZING THAT WE MAYBE
HAVE OPPORTUNITY ADDRESS THAT
SOON BUT I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE BILL I APPRECIATE THE
CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH A
CHAIR. ANY PARTICULARLY IN
REALLY A MAKING SURE IT'S
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR WITH THE
ADOPTION OF A RESOLUTION.
TO ALL INVOLVED THAT THERE'S
THIS MAY HAPPENS
I HONESTLY THIS BILL BECOMES
MOOT. IF MOST WHAT CAN THAT STEP
FORWARD LINK OUT AS SOMEBODY
SERVE ON THE CITY COUNCIL IS
OFTEN TOLD THAT WAS A TOUGH JOB
I WOULD ALWAYS ANSWER. BEYOND A
CHILE IS EVEN HARDER.
AND SO I UNDERSTAND THE
MEDICINES TO GET INVOLVED I LIKE
THE CHAIR AND I THINK LIKE THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LOT
OF COMPETITION IN THESE RACES.
UP BUT ULTIMATELY I HAVE A
STRONG CONCERN ABOUT THE OVERALL
COST OF H. AWAY FEES AND WHAT
THAT MEANS A TO HOMEOWNERSHIP IN
OUR STATE. AND IF THERE'S AN
EFFICIENCY THE TABLE TO BE
ACHIEVED A PARTICULAR WITH THE
LACK OF COMPETITION.
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY I WOULD KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE TO THE FIVE CITIES
IN MY DISTRICT.
HAD TO CANCEL THE LAST
ELECTIONS FOR LACK OF A
COMPETITIVE RACES.
IF WE CAN DO IT FOR
MUNICIPALITIES I'M NOT SURE WHY
THAT WOULD APPLY TO EACH WAYS.
IT WOULD BE A GRADUAL
CIRCUMSTANCE I THINK COMPETITION
IS GREAT BUT IT'S THE REALITY
BEHIND OUR SELVES AND I'LL MOVE
THE BILL.
AND LOOK WHAT ADDITIONAL
DIALOGUE IN JUDICIARY ON THE
FLOOR CHARACTERS MOTION MOVE IS
OUR SECOND.
SECOND BY DOCTOR WOULD UP
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
BY THE COMMITTEE.
HER CENTER GIVE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
INCINERATION GREAT THANK YOU SO
THERE IS A MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION IN ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHIU AYE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHILI AYE CHOI AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA I WE MONTH.
THE MONTH I WOULD. WOULD DIE
SENATOR BILLS OUT THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO NOW TO FILE ITEM THREE
CENTER SKINNER SP TWELVE.
SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING. MORNING THANK YOU
I CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
ALLOWS.
HOUSING THAT IS BUILT
SPECIFICALLY FOR STUDENTS TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE STATE'S DENSITY
BONUS.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS WHOSE
NEEDS.
STUDENT HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
ARE.
HAVE FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
NEEDS THAN OTHER TYPES OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
AND I'LL GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE
ARE.
STATE BONUS OUR STATE DENSITY
BONUS LAW IS BASED ON UNITS.
VERY OFTEN A STUDENT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION LIKE A DORM. HAS.
ROOMS OR MULTIPLE BEDS.
A SINGLE COMMON KITCHEN OR
PERHAPS A WHAT SINGLE BATHROOM
ON THE FLOOR. AND NOT WHAT ONE
CONSIDERS TYPICAL UNITS
SO GIVEN THAT CONFIGURATION. IT
IS SO FAR BEEN UNABLE FOR THOSE
DEVELOPERS OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
HUNDRED PERCENT FOR STUDENT
HOUSING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CALIFORNIA'S
DENSITY BONUS.
KNOW WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS MAKE
THE STUDENT HOUSING ELIGIBLE IF
IT IS DEDICATED ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. FOR STUDENTS
STUDENTS MUST BE ENROLLED IN THE
WESTERN ASSOCIATION. OF SCHOOLS
AND COLLEGES ACCREDITED
INSTITUTIONS OR THE EQUIVALENT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND THAT A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE UNITS BE
DEDICATED. TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS VIA FINANCIAL AID
ELIGIBILITY AND I'M ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEVELOPER TO
PROVIDE PROOF OF A. OPERATING
AGREEMENT OR MASTER LEASE THAT
SHOWS THAT IT'S POOR STUDENT
HOUSING.
AND I AM DELETING THE OPTION
AROUND.
PROOF OF FAMILY INCOME. AS.
RECOMMENDED BY THE.
COMMITTEE
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO HAVE
MY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
SURE MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL REPRESENT THE TOP
EMPLOYERS IN THE NINE COUNTY. OF
FAIR REGION A WHICH IS ALSO HOME
TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NBA
CHAMPIONS THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
.
YOU KNOW ARE ARE ARE EMPLOYERS
HAVE TOLD US THAT.
CREATE A SKILLED WORKFORCE OF
THE FUTURE THE TOP PRIORITY FOR
THEM AND IS OUR CHALLENGE
BECAUSE TWO THOUSAND SO
DIFFICULT. THAT IT'S THAT. THE
WE HAVE SO MANY STUDENTS LEAVING
AND GOING TO OTHER STATES FOR
THEIR EDUCATION NOT COME TO
CALIFORNIA. NOT STAYING HERE
BECOMING ENTREPRENEURS
BECOME A PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS ARE
SOCIETY ON WOULD LIKE TO APPLAUD
CENTER SKINNER FOR LEADERSHIP.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ISSUE TWO
HOUSES OF PARAMOUNT ISSUE FOR
THE BAY AREA FOR CALIFORNIA A
WHISPER BECAUSE WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS. EXCUSE ME MARK MCDONALD
MCCALLUM GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
FOOTHILL DE ANZA KERN AND
PERALTA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT ALSO WANTED TO WEIGH
IN.
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE.
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA THE THE
TRADE GROUP REPRESENTS ALL
SEVENTY TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS. HE WAS UNABLE TO MAKE
IT TODAY BUT.
.
AFFORDABILITY AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS MORE THAN JUST.
FEES AND HOUSING IS A MAJOR
PART OF THAT.
I THINK THE ANALYSIS DOES A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF POINTING OUT
THE NEED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL FOR THIS BILL.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THERE'S ONLY A FEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT ACTUALLY
HAVE DORMS SO THIS PROVIDES A
SOLUTION IN LIEU OF DORMS FOR
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WE
WOULD URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
OTHER SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING ASSISTANCE AND ONLY
AFTER CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATIONS.
TIFFANY FAN OF HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS BROWN TABBY HAVE OF
CALIFORNIAN BE IT'S PART.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I JUST WANNA
START BY THANKING THE SENATOR
FOR MOVING FORWARD.
AT SUCH AN INNOVATIVE SOLUTION
TO YET ANOTHER FACET OF OUR
STATE HOUSING CRISIS I THINK ALL
OF US HAVE SEEN. THE HOUSING
CRISIS IMPACTING.
NOT JUST FAMILIES NOTJUST
WORKERS BUT CERTAINLY STUDENTS
AND I THINK THIS IS A.
INTERESTING WAY OF GOING AT IT
AND ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS ARE WHICH I'LL JUST
NOTE BECAUSE OF TIMING ISSUES
WILL NOT BE TAKEN HERE BUT WILL
BE TAKEN AND. ARE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
WHEN THIS BILLS IN THAT
COMMITTEE SHORTLY IF THAT IS THE
WILL OF THIS COMMITTEE WITHOUT
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS DR WOULD.
SO I THINK THIS BE A EXCELLENT
BILL FOR THIS GOLDEN STATE LIKE
TO MOVE IT.
RIGHT MOTION MOVED THERE'S BEEN
A SECOND ANY FURTHER
CONVERSATION.
OKAY. OKAY I HAVE A QUESTION.
DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY AYE UP ONE ON WHAT WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS.
IT DID YOU UP OPPOSE SO A SO
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ACTUALLY A
HIGHLIGHTED IN WELL I REALIZE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ONE WOULD
DELETE THE OPTION. OF PROVIDING
ALTERNATIVE PROOF OF INCOME TO
QUALIFY FOR LOWER INCOME UNITS
OR PUT A DIFFERENT WAY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO REALLY NEED.
THAT HELP TO LIVE IN AND AND
THESE UNITS THE OTHER REQUIRES A
DEVELOPER TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE.
THAT THEY HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
THE LOCAL UNIVERSITY OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO PROVIDE A
TO STUDENTS TO LIVE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT SO. THE SECOND
REQUIREMENT SAYS THE DEVELOPER
ARE YOU REALLY BUILDING STUDENT
HOUSING AND HAVE AN AGREEMENT
WITH LOCAL UNIVERSITIES TO DO SO
SO WE'RE REALLY. UP PUTTING
BELTS AND SUSPENDERS
REQUIREMENTS BOTH ON THE STUDENT
SIDE AS WELL AS ON THE DEVELOPER
SIDE SO THAT IT STUDENTS WHO WHO
NEED TO LIVE IN THE US AND IT'S
A DEVELOPER WHO IS COMMITTED. TO
DOING THIS WORK WITH A SPECIFIC
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION.
OKAY I HAVE A LOT TO QUESTIONS.
NOT TO SENATOR ON THE MOON IS
THAT.
I ASSUME THAT THIS UP BILL
WOULD APPLY TO THE DEVELOPMENTS
ARE.
OH FIVE HOUSING OUTSIDE OF THE
CAMPUS
YES YES BECAUSE INSIDE IS SO UP
TO THE UNIVERSITY CORRECT AND
THEY AND AT LEAST ARE.
PUBLICLY OWNED UNIVERSITIES AND
HEARD AND DEPENDING ON THEIR
STATUS DON'T.
DON'T NEED THIS RELIEF BECAUSE.
THEY CAN APPLY THEIR OWN.
.
IT YEAH UNIVERSITY WOULD SET UP
BUT THEY OWN REGULATIONS OKAY
NUMBER TWO IS THAT I THOUGHT OF
THIS ARE A SPECIFIC.
THE OUR LOW INCOME HOUSING AND
A THIRTY FIVE PERCENT THE ATTEND
STEVE WARNER SO IS IN EFFECT A
IN OUR END OF THE.
STATUTES IS THAT TRUE. YES THE
DENSITY BONUS IS IN STATUTE BUT
IT'S BASED ON UNITS AND AS I
DESCRIBE IN MY OPENING.
CONFIGURATION OF STUDENT
HOUSING.
ONE COULD CONSIDER A DORM. I'D
IN EFFECT EITHER ONE UNIT OR IT
COULD TAKE AT BECAUSE THAT.
WHOLE DOOR MIGHT HAVE ONLY ONE
KITCHEN.
AND THREE BATHROOMS.
SO WITH THIS IS GOING TO ALLOW
THE DENSITY BONUS ON EITHER
BEDS.
OR BEDROOMS.
SO. YOU'RE NOT.
M. MAKE THE DISTINCTION ANY ARE
A STUDENT HOUSING. OUT WILL HAVE
A. NO SIMILAR TESTIMONY SHREK
CORRECT. NICK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE ALL* CENTER HERE
ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
ONLY SAY THAT I DID NOT MENTION
MY OPENING BUT IT WAS REFERRED
OBVIOUSLY IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND BY THE.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THAT.
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA HOUSING
COSTS
FOR MANY STUDENTS IS BEING
NUMBER ONE FINANCIAL PRESSURE.
AND SO THAT WHILE THIS WILL NOT
COMPLETELY SOLVE THAT IT
CERTAINLY WILL HELP BECAUSE IT
GIVES.
SOME DEVELOPERS IN MOTIVATION TO
BUILD HOUSING JUST FOR STUDENTS
SO WITH THAT I ASK BROUGH. THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CHU. CHU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI GAI CHILE I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE IN THE MONTH.
THE MONEY I WOULD. WOULD I.
SENATOR DOLE'S UP.
WITH ONE FINAL ITEM TODAY.
AND THAT IS.
YET WHEN WE JUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO DO THE CONSENT ITEM WHICH IS
FILE ITEM FOR SP ELEVEN SEVENTY
THREE BY DECK IS OUR MOTION TO
MOVE.
UP MOTION BY DR WOULD SECONDED
BY MISTER GLORIA.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
DIDN'T DO PASSED THE CONSENT.
CHIU BY TWO I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT CHAU.
JOE Y. CHILLY. CHILLY I GLORIA
GLORY I IN THE MONTH. NUMAN I
WOULD.
GOOD I THE CONSENT ITEMS OUT NOW
OUR FINAL ITEM FILE ITEM ONE S.
B. TEN SIXTEEN SIR ALAN WELCOME.
PAGE SO MUCH MEMBERS APPRECIATE
IT I THIS ISSUE COMES UP AS A
RESPONSE TO OF A REAL PROBLEM
THAT EXISTS FOR SOME FOLKS
AROUND THE STATE. IVERSON I
THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK ON ON THIS
BILL.
I HAD THIS BILL SEEKS TO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS CLIMATE AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION COSTS BY
ELIMINATING OBSTACLES THAT.
COULD PREVENT CONDOMINIUM
RESIDENTS FROM ACCESSING
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. CHARGING
STATIONS SAYS EVERYBODY KNOWS
CALIFORNIA HAS AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS SET FORTH IN AB THIRTY TWO
IN S. B.. THIRTY TWO AND.
UNDER THOSE GOALS THE STATE HAS
TO NOW DO MORE TO LIMIT THE
BARRIERS OF.
THAT MAY EXIST WITH REGARDS TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLE OWNERSHIP.
NOW THE GOVERNOR'S RECENT
OUTSIDE THE CALIFORNIA WILL PUT
FIVE MILLION ELECTRIC CARS ON
THE ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY MAKE
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM EVEN MORE
URGENT.
I KNOW WHAT THE PRICE OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES HAS BEEN
STEADILY DECREASING.
THE ACCESSIBILITY OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS
CONTINUES.
TO BE AN ISSUE.
NOW RESIDENTS WHO BELONG TO
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS AND
CONDOMINIUM COMPLEXES OFTEN FIND
IT DIFFICULT TO MAKE THE SWITCH
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO USE. COMMON AREA
SPACES TO INSTALL THE NEEDED
CHARGING OF STRUCTURE I HAPPEN
TO HAVE.
OUR OWN LITTLE GARAGE SO I CAN
PLUG AYE WE THAT I HAVE TOTAL
CONTROL OVER SO I CAN PLUG MY.
A MY.
ARE CHARGER INTO THE INTO OUR
OWN WALL THAT PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
COLLECTIVE SPACES WHERE THEY'RE
USING CHANGING. I'VE PARKING
SPACES HAVE SOME CHALLENGES IN
THIS RESPECT.
NO CURRENT LAW PROHIBITS A
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION FROM
UNREASONABLY RESTRICTING A
RESIDENTS ABILITY TO INSTALL A
CHARGING STATION AT THEIR OWN
COST BUT IT'S SILENT REGARDING
THE REMAINING NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDING THE
TIME OF USE METER THAT MAKES
EVEY IS MORE ECONOMICAL SO THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THIS GAP
TOMORROW BY PROHIBITING.
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS FROM
RESTRICTING THE ABILITY
RESIDENTS TO INSTALL A TIME OF
USE METER. AND A COMPANY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A COMMON AREA
WHERE THEIR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION IS LOCATED THE
BILL PASS OF THE SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT RECEIVED
NO. NO VOTES IT HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION WE WORK
CAREFULLY TO. MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S.
VERY TARGETED TO THIS
PARTICULAR CHALLENGE IN AND I
ASKED YOU ABOUT.
THANK YOU LET ME ASK IF THERE
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
I MISSED CARE MEMBERS
BOATBUILDER A BEHALF TESLA
MOTORS IN SPORT THINK.
MR TURN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT.
AND LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS.
MOTION WITH THE BILL AND THERE'S
A SECOND I JUST WANT TO SAY TO
THE.
SENATE AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR
MOVING THIS FORWARD AND.
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A
STRICT FOR BILL AND AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS ALSO BEEN TRYING TO
CHAMPION MORE INSTALLATIONS OF
PHOEBE CHARGING STATIONS. ARE
APPLAUD THIS AND IF YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ADDITIONAL CO
AUTHORS OF THE HAPPY BE ADDED.
SALINAS WITH THAT UNLESS THERE'S
ANY FURTHER CONVERSATION UNLESS
YOU HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS UP
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
DOCTOR CHOI. YEAH WELL NO
QUESTION.
IT WAS JUST A DOG WITH A YA*
AWAY WHY NOT BLOW.
WHAT CAN WE BELIEVE AT THIS COME
UP WITH A PLAN NOW REQUIRE MY
STEP CLOSER EVERY HOMEOWNER
WILL?
THEIR COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT AREA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION NOT WOULD HAVE
THIER.
A BOARD MEMBER SAYS SITUATIONS
WOULD BE OR DIFFERENT THAT THEY
CAN DECIDE THAT WHY DO WE HAVE
TO.
I INTERVENED THEY OWN LOCAL
AUTHORITY.
SO THE ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH THEM
THE QUESTION OF TIME OF USE
METERS.
AND SO.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR
THE MOST PART THEY'RE HAVING
MANY PROBLEMS AROUND THE STATE I
THINK IF YOU LOOK YOU KNOW. AS
YOU KNOW I SERVE ON THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE SIDE.
THERE A LOT OF INTEREST GROUPS
TO COME IN IF THEY FEEL AS
THOUGH A BILL HAVE YOU. CREATES
ONEROUS OVERREGULATION OF
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN THIS
CASE WE'VE MET WITH THEM WE TALK
TO THEM AND AND AND THEY DON'T
FEEL AS THOUGH THIS IS ONEROUS.
BUT BUT ONLY ULTIMATELY IT'S
IMPORTANT SO THAT IF THERE'S ANY
BIT BASICALLY IN ORDER TO ALLOW
US TO REACH THE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE. WE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO LIVING IN COMMON
USE PARKING.
CONDOMINIUMS HAVE ACCESS TO TIME
OF USE METER MEASURES.
AND SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO BARRIERS TO.
TO THE ACCESS TO THE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR TYPE OF OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NEEDED.
I MEAN YOU KNOW I THINK THE
CONCERNS I I'M A MEMBER OF ANY
CHOI SOMETIMES YOU HAVE FOLKS
WHO ARE STILL NOT QUITE OF A OF
A WHERE. BATTAGLIA'S AS ELECTRIC
CARS ARE GETTING MORE MORE
POPULAR IT'S A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
JUST HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT WHAT IT
TAKES TO. HAVE A MUCH REQUIRED
IT TO CHARGE IT I'M.
AND IN THE NEEDS NOT BE
SENSITIVE TO THE.
THE PARTICULAR NEEDS OF ELECTRIC
CARS.
SO AS I SAY WE'VE WE'VE.
ARE MAKING YOU KNOW JUST AS WELL
AS I THAT THERE THAT THERE ARE
LOTS OF BILLS THAT THAT
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION COMMUNITY
OBJECT TO YOU BECAUSE THEY FEEL
AS THOUGH THERE'S
MICROMANAGEMENT IN THIS CASE.
I THEY DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH
THAT'S THE CASE.
IT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
IDEA OF.
COMMON CHARGING STATION.
SO THIS ALL HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT YOU ELECTRIC
ELECTRICITY PRICES VARY BY THE
TIME OF DAY.
AND SO THEIR FOLKS YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE.
I DID THERE BEING PROPERLY
CHARGED.
NO PUN INTENDED I'VE FOR.
FOR THE ELECTRICITY THEY'RE
USING BASED ON THE TIME OF DAY
THAT THEY'RE USING IT
SO CAN BE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE TO
CHARGE YOUR CAR AT CERTAIN TIMES
OF DAY THAN OTHER TIMES TODAY SO
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART. OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE. OTHER THE
CHARGING PROCESS IS ECONOMICAL
FOR FOLKS
SO YOU'LL BE IN IT WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER TO CHARGE ANY TIME.
WELL THE VERY LEAST IT WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
KNOW THAT TO BE ABLE TO TRACK
AND BE PROPERLY CHARGE FOR THE.
THAT THE THE ELECTRICITY USED
THAT THERE.
TAKING FROM THE SYSTEM TO CHARGE
OUR CARS BASED ON THE TIME OF
DAY THAT THEY'RE DOING.
SO YOU BELIEVE SO TRYING TO MAKE
IT EASIER WILL ARE HARDER OF IT
I MEAN WE'RE TRYING MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THESE FOR THESE
DRIVERS ABSOLUTELY.
DIDN'T TO MAKE IT YOU KNOW.
TO TURN TO DID IT GIVE THEM
ANOTHER TOOL.
I HAD TO TO UNDERSTAND AND BE
ABLE TO CHARGE THEIR CARS IN AN
ECONOMICAL MANNER TO UNDERSTAND
ELECTRICITY PRICES ASSOCIATED
WITH CHARGING AND. MAKE SURE
THEY'RE DOING IT TIMES A DAY
WHEN.
WHEN ONE IS LESS EXPENSIVE IF
THEY WANT TO.
ECONOMICAL MAN I MEAN IS THAT
THE YOU ARE TRYING TO RESTRICT
IT'LL TO CHARGE A AFTER
MIDNIGHT.
NO THEY CAN CHARGE WHATEVER THEY
WANT BUT THE BUT THE TIME OF USE
METER MONITORS WHEN THEY'RE
CHARGING AND HOW THEY'RE
CHARGING IN THE COMMAND OF.
OF OF CHARGES ARE USING. AND
THEY CAN THEN BE. CHARGED
FINANCIALLY ARE. YOU KNOW I
BASED ON ON THEIR USAGE BUT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME TO USE
MANNER.
THERE'S NO OUR WAY OF MONITORING
THE ELECTRICITY USE THAT YOU ARE
USING TWO I HAD TO CHARGE A CAR.
YOU THERE'S NO THERE'S NO WAY TO
MONITOR THE FACT THAT DID THAT
YOU CHARGE DURING A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME IS THIS AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY AND SO YOU ARE TO BE
CHARGED A CERTAIN AMOUNT.
BECAUSE WE CHARGE WE CHARGE
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS OF MONEY FOR
ELECTRICITY YOU SPACE ON THE
DIFFERENT TIMES OF THE DAY YEAH
I KNOW SO SO PEOPLE CAN YOU CAN
YOU CAN CHARGE AT NIGHT YOU
COULD CHARGE AND THAT YOU DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT. BUT IF YOU
HAVE A TIME OF USE METER. IT
ALLOWS YOU TO BE PROPERLY.
.
CHARGE FOR FOR THAT FOR THE
AMOUNT OF ELECTRICITY VIEWS IN
THE TIME OF DAY YOU'VE USED IT.
SO WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THERE'S NO
BARRIERS TO THE. IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT PARTICULAR TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE.
MY DO I NEED THAT THE.
A TIME UP TO YOU SAW.
THOUGH IT MONITORING UNITA IF I
IF I PAY MORE.
ANYTIME I CHARGE. RIGHT SO YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE IN FACT GREAT
SHOW A ACTUALLY HAS A MESSAGES I
MEAN DEPENDING ON HOW THEY. USE
THEIR.
DEPENDING HOW THEY STRUCTURE
THEIR ELECTRICITY CHARGES FOR
THAT FOR COMMON SPACES THEY
SOMETIMES WILL WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE. ARE YOU ARE IF
YOU'RE USING A LOT OF
ELECTRICITY DOWN THE COMMON
SPACE THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE AS
WELL THAT.
THEY HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHO'S USING AND WHEN. BUT THE
FACT IS FOR BETTER FOR WORSE AND
IN YOU WE CAN DISCUSS THIS AS
EVERYONE KNOWS IN THE ENERGY
SPACE. WE DO CHARGE DIFFERENT
AMOUNTS OF MONEY FOR DIFFERENT
TIMES A DAY. OF ELECTRICITY USE.
YOU KNOW I SOLAR GETS MORE AND
MORE ONLINE. IT ACTUALLY I THINK
IN SOME RESPECTS MAKES SENSE TO
START TO FLIP THE MODEL I
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE AN
EXCESS OF ENERGY DURING THE TILL
THE DAY.
AND AND AND IT DE AND AND NOT
AT NIGHT BUT RIGHT NOW BASED ON
THE OLD. THE OLD SYSTEM WERE
STILL CHARGING PEOPLE MORE FOR
ELECTRICITY USE.
DURING THE DAY THAN AT NIGHT.
AND THAT'S A BROADER KIND OF
PROBLEM THAT I LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON.
SOME MEMBER IF THAT'S OF
INTEREST.
THANK YOU UNLESS THERE'S ANY
FURTHER COMMENT CENTER DE OF ANY
FINAL CLOSING COMMENTS RECEIVED
THE DISCUSSION IN THE QUESTIONS
ADMITTED TO ME WITH YOUR OFFICE
TO TALK TO MORE ABOUT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND AND DONE.
YES IT'S COMMON SENSE.
REDUCTION OF A OF A OF A
POTENTIAL BARRIER.
IS TO ALLOW THE STATE TO GROW
ITS.
AND SAT IT'S ELECTRIC VEHICLE
FLEET IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH
THE PRIVATE MARKET. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECT CAST MY VOTE
GREAT NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FOR THE.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY CHIU AYE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHOW
CHOW Y..
CHILE.
JOIN THE BOARDING.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE LEE MON.
MARK I WOULD.
WHICH I.
YOUR BILLS OUT UNIVERSE AND WITH
THAT I THINK I DON'T THINK
ANYONE IS DEAD ON.
AT THIS TIME THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED